All the parameterizations
we've done so far have been
parameterizing a curve
using one parameter.
What we're going to start doing
this video is parameterizing a
surface in three dimensions,
using two parameters.
And we'll start with an
example of a torus.
A torus, or more commonly
known, as a doughnut shape.
And we know what a
doughnut looks like.
Let me draw it in a suitable,
well, I don't have any
suitable doughnut colors,
so I'll just use green.
A doughnut looks
something like this.
It has a hole in the center,
And maybe the other side of
the doughnut looks something
like that, and we could
shade it in like that.
That is what a
doughnut looks like.
So how do we construct that
using two parameters?
So what we want to do, is you
can just visualize it, a
doughnut, if you were to
draw some axes here.
So that's our doughut.
Let me draw some axes.
So let's say I have the z-axis
that goes straight up and down.
So we have drawn it here, the
doughnut's a little at a
tilt, so the z-axis, I'll
tilt it a little bit.
So our z-axis goes straight
through the center
of the doughnut.
So that right there, this is
going to be an exercise in
drawing more than
anything else.
So that is my z-axis, and then
you can imagine the z-axis goes
from there, and then this
coming out of here
will be my x-axis.
That right there is my x-axis,
and then maybe my y-axis
comes out like that.
And the whole reason why I drew
it this way, is that if you
imagine the cross section of
this doughnut, I'll draw a
little bit neater, but the
cross section of this doughnut
in the x-z axis, is going to
look something like this.
If I were to slice it in the
x-z axis, it would look
something like that.
That would be the slice.
It would trace out, and
we're thinking about not
a full doughnut, just the
surface of a doughnut.
So it would trace out
a circle like this.
If you were to cut the doughnut
in the positive z-y axis, it's
going to trace out a circle
that looks something
like that, right there.
And if you go out here, you're
going to get bunch of circles.
So if you think about it, it's
a bunch of circles rotated
around the z-axis.
If you think of it that way,
it'll give us some good
intuition for the best way
to parameterize this thing.
So let's do it that way.
Let's start off with
just the z-y axis.
I'll draw it a little bit
neater than I've done here.
So that is the z-axis, and
that is y, just like that.
And let's say that the center
of these circles, let's say it
lies on, you know, it can lie,
when you cross the z-y axis,
the center sits on the y-axis.
I didn't draw it that
neatly here, but I think
you can visualize.
So it sits right
there on the y-axis.
And let's say that it is a
distance b away from the center
of the torus, or from the
z-axis it's a distance of b.
It's always going to
be a distance of b.
It's always, if you imagine the
top of the doughnut, let me
draw the top of the doughnut.
If you're looking down on a
doughnut, let me draw a
doughnut right here, if you're
looking down on a doughnut, it
just looks something like that.
The z-axis is just going to
be popping straight out.
The x-axis would come down like
this, and then the y-axis would
go to the right, like that.
So you can imagine, I'm
just flying above this.
I'm sitting on the z-axis
looking down at the doughnut.
It will look just like this.
And if you imagine the cross
section, this circle right
here, the top part of the
circle if you're looking down,
would look just like that.
And this distance b is a
distance from the z-axis
to the center of each
of these circles.
So this distance, let me draw
it in the same color, from the
center to the center of these
circles, that is going to be b.
It's just going to keep
going to the center
of the circles, b.
That's going to be b,
that's going to be b.
That's going to be b.
From the center of our torus
to the center of our circle
that defines the torus,
it's a distance of b.
So this distance right here,
that distance right there is b.
And from b, we can imagine
we have a radius.
A radius of length a.
So these circles have
radius of length a.
So this distance right here is
a, this distance right here is
a, this distance right there
is a, that distance
right there is a.
If I were look at these
circles, these circles
have radius a.
And what we're going to do
is have two parameters.
One is the angle that this
radius makes with the x-z
plane, so you can imagine
the x-axis coming out.
Let me do that in
the same color.
You can imagine the
x-axis coming out here.
So this is the x-z plane.
So one parameter is going to
be the angle between our
radius and the x-z plane.
We're going to call that angle,
or that parameter, we're
going to call that s.
And so as s goes between 0 and
2 pi, as s goes between 0 in 2
pi, when the 0 is just going to
be at this point right here,
and then as it goes to 2 pi,
you're going to trace out a
circle that looks
just like that.
Now, we only have
one parameter.
What we want to do is then
spin this circle around.
What I just drew is that
circle right there.
What we want to do is spin
the entire circle around.
So let's define
another parameter.
We'll call this one t, and
I'll take the top view again.
This one's getting a
little bit messy.
Let me draw another top view.
As you can see, this is
all about visualization.
So let's say this is my
x-axis, that is my y-axis.
And we said we started
here on the z-y plane.
We are b away from the z-axis,
so that distance is b.
In this diagram, the z-axis
is just popping out at us.
It's popping out of the page.
We're looking straight down.
It's just like the same
view as right there.
And what I just drew, when s is
equal to 0 radians, we're going
to be out here, exactly
one radius further
along the y-axis.
And then we're going to rotate.
As we rotate around, we're
going to rotate and then
come all the way over here.
That's when we're right over
there, and then come back down.
So if you looked on the
top of the circle, it's
going to look like that.
Now, to make the doughnut,
we're going to have to
rotate this whole setup
around the z-axis.
Remember, the z-axis
is popping out.
It's looking straight up at us.
It's coming out of
your video screen.
Now to rotate it, we're
going to rotate this
circle around the z-axis.
And to do that, we'll define a
parameter that tells us how
much we have rotated it.
So this is when we've
rotated 0 radians.
At some point, we're going to
be over here, and we would
have rotated it, this is b as
well, and our circle is going
to be looking like this.
This is maybe this point on
our doughnut, right there.
At that point, we would
have rotated it,
let's say p radians.
So this parameter of how much
have we rotated around the
z-axis, how much have we gone
around that way, we're
going to call that t.
And t is also going to
vary between 0 and 2 pi.
And I want to make
this very clear.
Let's actually draw the domain
that we're mapping from to
our surface, so that we
understand this fully.
So let me draw some, and then
we'll talk about how we can
actually parameterize
that into a position
vector-valued function.
So right here, let's
call that the t-axis.
That's, remember, how much
we're rotated around
the z-axis right there.
And let's call this
down here our s-axis.
And I think this will help
things out a good bit.
So when s is equal to 0, and
we vary just t, so they're
both going to vary
between 0 and 2 pi.
So this right here is 0,
this right here is 2 pi.
Let me do some
things in between.
This is pi, this would be pi
over 2 obviously, pi over 2,
this would be 3 pi over 4.
You do the same thing
on the p-axis.
It's going to go up to 2 pi.
Let's do that.
So we're going to
go up to 2 pi.
I really want you to visualize
this, because then the
parameterization, I think, will
be fairly straightforward.
So that's 2 pi, this is pi,
this is pi over 2, and
then this is 3 pi over 4.
So let's think about what it
looks like if you just hold s
constant at 0, and we just
vary t between zero and 2 pi.
And let me do that in
magenta, right here.
So we're holding s constant,
and we're just varying
the parameter 2 pi.
So this, if you think about it,
should just form a curve in
three dimensions,
not a surface.
Because we're only varying
one parameter right here.
So let's think about
what this is.
Remember, s is, let
me draw my axes.
So that is my x-axis, that
is my y-axis, and then
this is my, I'm getting
messier and messier.
That is my z-axis, right--
actually, let me draw it a
little bit bigger than that.
I think it will help all
of our visualizations.
All right.
So this is my x-axis, that is
my y-axis, and then my z-axis
goes up like that. z-axis.
Now remember, when s is equal
to 0, that means we haven't
rotated around this
circle at all.
That means we're out here.
We're going to be b away,
and then a away again.
Right?
We haven't rotated
around this at all.
We're setting s as
equal to zero.
So essentially, we're going to
be b away, so this is going to
be a distance of b away, and
then we're going to
be another a away.
The b is the center of the
circle, and then we're going
to be another a away.
We're going to be
right over there.
So this is a plus b away.
And then we're going to vary t.
Remember, t was how much we've
gone around the z-axis.
These were top views over here.
So this line right here, in our
s-t domain, we can say, when we
map it, or parameterize it,
it'll correspond to the curve
that's essentially the outer
edge of are doughnut.
If this is the top view of the
doughnut, it will be the outer
edge of the doughnut,
just like that.
So let me draw the outer edge.
And to do that a little bit
better, let me draw the axes
in both the positive and
the negative domain.
It might make my graph a little
bit easier to visualize things.
Positive and negative domain,
this is negative z right there.
So this line in our t-s plane,
I guess we could say, this
magenta line, we hold s at 0
radians and we increase t, this
is t is zero, this is t is
equal to 2 pi, that's t is
equal to pi, this is t is equal
to 3 pi over 2, all the way
back to t is equal to 2 pi.
This line corresponds to that
line, as we rotate, as we
increase t and hold
s constant at 0.
Now let's do another point.
Let's say when s is at pi,
right, remember, when s is
at pi, we've gone exactly,
pi is 180 degrees.
When s is at pi, we've
gone exactly 180 degrees
around the circle, around
each of these circles.
So we're right over there.
And now let's hold it constant
at pi, and then rotate it
around to form our doughnut.
So we're going to form the
inside of our doughnut.
So when s is at pie, and we're
going to take t from 0, so when
s is pi and t is 0, we're going
to be, this was the center of
our circle, we're going
to be a below that.
We're going to be
right over there.
And then as we vary, as we
increase t, so as we move up
along, holding s at pi, and we
increase t, we're going to
trace out the inside of our
doughnut, that will look
something like that.
That was my best
shot at drawing it.
And then we can do
that multiple times.
When s is pi over 2, I want to
do multiple different colors,
when s is pi over 2, we've
rotated up here exactly
90 degrees, right?
Pi over 2 is 90 degrees
at this point.
And then if we vary t, we're
essentially tracing out the
top of the doughnut, right?
So let me make sure I draw it .
So the cross section, the top
of the doughnut, we're going
to start off right over here.
So when s is pi over 2, and you
vary it right, and then you
very t, I'm having trouble
drawing straight lines.
And then you vary t, it's
going to look like this.
That's the top of that
circle right there.
The top of this circle is
going to be right there.
going to be right over there.
Top of the circle is going
to be right over there.
So then I just
connect the dots.
It's going to look
something like that.
That is the top
of our doughnut.
If I was doing this top view,
it would be the top of the
doughnut, just like that.
And if I wanted to do the
bottom of the doughnut, just to
make the picture clear, if I
were to make the bottom of the
doughnut, the bottom of the
doughnut would be-- see, if I
take s as 3 pi over 4 and I
vary t, that's the bottoms
of our doughnuts.
So let me draw the circle, it's
right there, the circle is
right there, you wouldn't be
able to see the whole thing
if this wasn't transparent.
So you'd be tracing out the
bottom of the doughnut,
just like that.
I know this graph is becoming
a little confusing, but
hopefully you get the idea.
When s is 2 pi again, you're
going to be back to the outside
of the doughnut again.
That's also going
to be in purple.
So that's what happens when we
hold the s constant at certain
values and vary the t.
Now let's do the opposite.
What happens if we hold t
at 0, and we very the s?
So t is 0, that means we
haven't rotated at all yet.
So we're in the z-y plane.
So t is 0, and s will start at
0, and it'll go to pi over 2,
that's that point over there.
Then it'll go to pi.
This point is the same
thing as that point.
Then it will go to 3 pi over
4, then it'll come back
all the way to 2 pi.
So this line corresponds to
this circle, right there.
We could keep doing these if we
pick when t is pi -- let me use
a different color, that's
not different enough.
When t is pi over
2, just like that.
We would have rotated around
the z-axis 90 degrees,
so now we're over here.
And now when we vary s, s will
start off over here, and
it'll go all the way
around like that.
So this line corresponds
to that circle.
We could keep doing
it like this.
When t is equal to pi, that
means we've got all the way
around the circle like that,
and now when we vary s from 0
to pi over 2, we're going to
start all the way over here,
and then we're going to vary,
all the way, we're going to go
down and hit all those contours
that we talked about before,
and I'll do one more, just
to kind of make this,
the scaffold, clear.
This dark purple,
hopefully you can see it.
When t is 3 pi over 4,
we've rotated all the way.
So we're in the x-z plane.
And then when you vary s, s
will start off over here, and
as you increase s, you're going
to go around the circle, around
the circle, just like that.
And of course, when you get all
the way back full circle, t
over pi over 2, that's
the same thing.
You're back over here again.
So this is going to be, we can
even shade it the same color.
And hopefully you're
getting a sense now of
the parameterization.
I haven't done any math yet.
I haven't actually showed you
how to mathematically represent
it as a vector value function,
but hopefully you're getting
a sense of what it means to
parameterize by two parameters.
And just to get an idea of what
these areas on our s-t plane
correspond to onto this
surface, in I guess you could
say, in R3, this little square
right here, let's see
what's bounded by.
This little square, I want to
make sure I picked a square
that I can draw neatly.
So this square right here, that
is between, when you look at t,
it's between 0 and pi over 2.
And s is between
0 and pi over 2.
So this right here is
this part of our torus.
If you're looking at it from
the top, it would look
like that, right there.
You can imagine, we've
transformed this square.
I haven't even shown you how
to do it mathematically yet.
But we've transformed
this square to this
part of the doughnut.
Now, I think we've done about
as much as I can do on
the visualization side.
I'll stop this video here.
In the next video, we're going
to actually talk about, how
do we actually parameterize
using these two parameters?
Remember, s takes around each
of these circles, and then t
takes us around the z-axis.
And if you take all of the
combinations of s and t, you're
going to have every point
along the surface of this
torus or this doughnut.
How do you actually go from an
s and a t that goes from 0 to
2 pi, in both cases, and turn
it into a three-dimensional
position vector-valued function
that would define this surface?
We're going to do that
in the next video.